all right I I I I I get the cries from
some quarters in society where people
say it's a deliberate thing to actually
completely dismantle relationships
because that almost seems the only
logical explanation is like this almost
like this real concerted effort to
completely dismantle marriage because
that's the only way you can explain it
to a certain extent isn't it because
some of the laws are so crazy so stupid
I'm so Sinister there is like that is
not fostering proper relationships
proper marriage and we can see the stats
of you know especially boys from single
parent families I mean my God from crime
to health to life chances to every stat
goes against them so why are we a
society pushing this real almost like an
agenda to split